hallo und herzlich willkommen zur gemüse
partner gehört ich möchte dir in diesem
video zeigen welche gemüse wirklich gut
zusammen passen also wir werden jetzt
deine ganzen einsamen gemüse die du
nächstes jahr anbauen möchtest
verkuppeln schüssel dass jeder den
passenden partner findet ich finde dass
nämlich immer ganz schön schwierig wenn
man so eine lange liste hat von lauter
mischkulturen die irgendwie
zusammenpassen könnten
und deswegen möchte ich hier ganz
konkrete beispiele zeigen von
mischkultur partnerschaften die bei uns
super gut funktionieren so gut dass wir
jedes jahr immer wieder genau so
zusammen anbauen und die möchte ich
heute mit dir teilen es gibt auch eine
pflanzen gemeinschaft die absolut
überhaupt nicht miteinander können das
musste ich auch schon am eigenen leib
erfahren wie das ist wenn man die
nebeneinander zu angst darüber werden
wir auch sprechen falls du mich noch
nicht kennst ich bin marie ich mache
videos rund um das thema
selbstversorgung aus dem garten also
abonnieren gerne meinen kanal und klickt
die glocke damit du keine neuen videos
mehr verpasst ich freue mich auch immer
über einen daumen hoch
lasst uns loslegen mit dem video und
zwar ist das hier das zweite video in
meiner an bauplan reihe ich möchte dem
ich helfen wie du deinen an bauplan
erstellt so dass er wirklich
ausgeklügelt ist also schau dir das
erste video auf jeden fall noch mal an
da erkläre ich ganz genau was ist alles
braucht um einen anbau plan zu erstellen
ein paar davon ist die mischkultur darum
geht es in diesem video aber um noch mal
den überblick zu bekommen schau dir auf
jeden fall erstmal das andere an bauplan
video anämische kultur hat super viele
vorteile
das kann sein dass pflanzen wenn man sie
nebeneinander gepflanzt wie schädlinge
und krankheiten vom leib halten das ist
super praktisch es kann sein dass sie
die nährstoffe im boden sehr
unterschiedlich nutzen und deswegen gut
zusammenpasst
dass sie den platz gut ausnutzen also
manchmal bausch hohe pflanzen wie
knoblauch gerne zusammen mit niedrigeren
pflanzen wie erdbeeren an
einfach weil ja so ein bisschen wie
tetris spielen die eine wächst nach oben
die anderen bedeckt den boden
das passt dann super gut zusammen es
gibt pflanzen die sich gegenseitig
stützen generell ist es immer sinnvoll
den garten möglichst bunt zu bepflanzen
möglichst wenig flächen mit ein und
demselben gemüse zu bepflanzen sondern
immer eine vielfältige mischung zu haben
weil egal welcher schädling oder welche
krankheit kommt wenn jeder ein feld voll
mit ihrem lieblingsessen finden dann
haben sie es ganz leicht sich da
auszubreiten aber wenn immer bei andere
pflanzen dazwischen wachsen dann ist das
eben schon viel schwieriger und so wird
dein garten einfach wie sie etwa das
geht sogar so weit dass ihr mehr
mischkultur du in deinem garten macht
also die buntheit eine beete bepflanzt
sind desto weniger muss du auf die
fruchtfolge achten weil einfach alles so
durchmischt ist und so vielfältig dass
krankheiten und schädlinge einfach es
nicht so leicht haben sich in deinem
garten breit zu machen
ich hab's ja eben schon erwähnt
erdbeeren und knoblauch sind eine
supertolle mischkultur die kommen bei
mir immer zusammen ins bett das ist auch
super praktisch weil mein erdbeeren jahr
im besten fall im august pflanzt im
oktober kann man dann den knoblauch
dazwischen stecken nichts passiert dann
auch immer extra ein stück weiter
auseinander damit dazwischen noch eine
reihe andere gemüse wachsen können der
knoblauch den ernten man immer zur
sommersonnenwende also ende juni/anfang
juli und dann ist es noch zeit eine
reihe buschbohnen dazwischen zu sehen
wenn der knoblauch aus ist das ist die
zweite supertolle mischkultur mit
erdbeeren zusammen also der knoblauch
sorgt dafür dass die erdbeeren nicht so
schnell von pilzkrankheiten befallen
werden und die busch boden fixieren
stickstoff im boden was den erdbeeren an
zugute kommt also die erdbeeren werden
immer ein bisschen weiter auseinander
kleinst und dann kommt dazwischen die
buschbohnen und wenn die busspuren dann
abgeerntet sind dann sind die erdbeeren
meistens so buschek dass sie den platz
selber einnehmen aber dann könnte man
natürlich auch noch eine andere struktur
mit in den eltern zusammen anbauen aber
ich mache das immer so dass es dann im
ersten jahr steht da der knoblauch
zusammen dann kommen die busspuren drauf
und danach so lange wie die erdbeeren
dann noch im bett stehen ja stehen sie
dann bei mir alleine aber wenn ihr noch
eine tolle mischkultur hat was auch gut
mit erdbeeren funktioniert würde mich
das sehr interessieren weil ich habe
gerade ein beet das jetzt durch ist mit
knoblauch und mit bus oder sich da jetzt
auch noch neugierig bin was ich da noch
dazu pflanzen könnte also wenn sich da
irgendwas für euch gut bewährt hat lasst
es mich gerne unten in den kommentaren
wissen dann kommt ein ziemlich
klassisches beispiel die möhre und die
zwiebel
ich habe überlegt ob ich die überhaupt
hier mit reinnehmen soll weil das
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch weiß dass
die super gut zusammenpassen aber das
funktioniert einfach so so gut dass ich
das einfach mit aufnehmen musste ich bei
immer höheren und zwiebeln nebeneinander
an und es hat einen grund warum das die
klassische mischkultur ist oder das
beispiel was immer alle verwenden wenn
sie versuchen mischkultur zu erklären
weil die röhre die zwiebel fliege
vertreibt und die zwiebel die möhren
pflege und das funktioniert sehr
zuverlässig es gibt auch noch mehr
ähnliche kombinationen in die richtung
also möhre mit knoblauch funktioniert
auch sehr gut lobte sich bringen sind
tolle pflanzen ist eine gute kultur
partner für alle möglichen gemüse möhren
mit lauch kammern probieren der lauf
wird als sehr schnell von der laufruhige
befallen
diese schon sehr hartnäckig aber wenn du
komplett auf netze verzichten möchtest
und lauf an bauen willst dann probiert
es mal mit möhren und lauch zusammen
dann kannst du auch pastinaken und
knoblauch zusammen anbauen also die
passen auch sehr gut zusammen da gibt es
eine ganze reihe von gemüsen also die
aus der zwiebel familie und die möhren
und pastinaken kann man alle sehr gut
miteinander kombinieren bei mir wächst
laut aber immer immer immer mit dem pool
zusammen auf einen wert weil ich einfach
so viele probleme mit der lauf fliege
hat sich da keine lust mehr drauf habe
da kommt jetzt immer nett rüber
ich nehme dann hätte die relativ stabil
sind so dass man die also ich benutze
jetzt seit fünf sechs jahren um diesen
nicht kaputt ist es immer so eine sache
eine plastik im garten verwenden ja oder
nein in dem fall finde ich es angebracht
weil sowohl cool als auch laut werden
einfach weggefressen wenn man da nicht
aufpasst dass es viel zu schade und dann
plant sich immer noch sellerie mit auf
dieses beet also kohl auf und sellerie
wachsen bei mir zusammen in einem beet
weil der sellerie noch eine
schutzfunktion hat für den cool
der vertreibt die schädlinge noch mal
extra das heißt selbst wenn mal irgendwo
das netz flatterte verfüge und irgendwo
tiere darunter kommen können dann ist da
immer noch derselbe wie der seinen duft
verströmen für die schädlinge ablenken
soll
dann kommt noch eine wunderbare
mischkultur das milka oder indianer das
haben sich ja auch schon einige von euch
ausprobiert dass man zucker reis oder
mais generell zusammen mit stangenbohnen
und kürbisanbau der kürbis bedeckt den
boden die stangenbohnen wachsen an denen
meist langen hoch und fixieren
stickstoff im boden das ist eine super
mischkultur es ist allerdings wichtig
dass man da diese sollten so aufeinander
abstimmen
dass der meist schnell genug wächst um
nicht von der bohne überwuchert zu
werden oder umgekehrt also das ist immer
so ein bisschen so
kunststück der kürbis das ist eigentlich
relativ egal welche sorten anbaut suite
ampfing was auch immer aber bei den
meister passt die sorte tram und sehr
gut zusammen mit der sorte neckar
königin das ist die stadt ohne dann also
die wachsen eben im gleichen takt so
dass es dann meistens sehr gut
funktioniert ja das ist schon einfach
eine der coolsten mischkulturen
überhaupt immer verraten was eure
liebste mischkultur partnerschaft ist
ein welche gemüse ihr immer wieder
zusammen anbaut weil es so gut
funktioniert hat ich freue mich immer
über eure kommentare jetzt verrate ich
euch noch die pflanzen gemeinschaft die
ich im all zusammen angebaut habe die
überhaupt nicht gut funktioniert hat und
ich hätte das eigentlich wissen müssen
dass waren freiland tomaten und
kartoffeln und die sind ja beide
anfällig für die braunfäule das ist eine
krankheit die beiden pflanzen sehr
zusetzt sind ja auch beides
nachtschattengewächse die dafür sehr
anfällig sind dadurch dass sich die so
dicht beieinander angebaut habe hatte
ich einfach ich glaube im juni schon in
schrecklichen befall und das hat
überhaupt nicht funktioniert also
kartoffeln und tomaten sind der ball zu
pflanzen die man eigentlich super gerne
im garten anbaut immer so bald wie
möglich auseinander anbauen also das war
mir wirklich eine leere weil werten in
dem jahr
ich glaube wir haben kaum eigene tomaten
geerntet und die kartoffeln man alle
foul
also bitte mittel wird so immer in
großen sicherheitsabstand waren also die
pflanze ich jetzt immer so weit wie
möglich auseinander mittlerweile bei
euch sogar kartoffeln nur noch auf
unserem acker an also einem komplett
anderen garten und die tomaten wachsen
hier im küchengarten ich finde es noch
wichtig zu sagen dass mischkultur kein
allheilmittel ist also wenn dein
schädlings druck in deinem garten
einfach super hoch ist dann kann es sein
dass deine pflanzen trotzdem befallen
werden aber solange das moderat ist also
so lange da nicht 1000 zwiebel fliegen
schwirren die ganz hungrig sind auf
deine zwiebeln funktioniert das sehr
sehr gut ich habe damit super
erfahrungen gemacht und es ist einfach
eine
fähigkeit wie man sehr einfach und sehr
wirkungsvoll ohne chemie keule auspacken
zu müssen und ganz natürlich dafür
sorgen kann dass der garten möglichst
gesund bleibt und deswegen ist
mischkultur wirklich ein thema aber mir
ist es super wichtig ich bin super super
zufrieden mit dem mischkultur
partnerschaften die ich euch gerade
vorgestellt habe es gibt noch viel mehr
also wenn ihr noch mal die liste
anschauen möchte kann ich die euch auch
gerne nochmal hier verlinken
bei einfach es gibt super viele
möglichkeiten und kombinationen und man
baut ja nicht auch gar nicht immer die
gemüse an die ich jetzt hier
vorgestellte weil sie vielleicht mag es
einfach keinen knoblauch und gerne
beschworen hinten kannst du dir unten
nochmal anschauen dass du stattdessen
wie kombinieren könntest du kannst du
natürlich immer auf meinen fertigen
anbauplanung herunterladen wenn du
merkst dass dir das alles zu kompliziert
wird mit dem ganzen kombinationen da ist
das alles schon beachtet also da wachsen
nur gemüse zusammen die auch wirklich
gut miteinander funktionieren die
fruchtfolge ist schon ausgetüftelt das
ist alles so betagte dass du
kontinuierlich aus seinem garten ernten
kann zudem kannst du dir auch gerne hier
unter dem video herunterladen
der ist wirklich schon fertig für dich
durchdacht den hals zu eins zu eins
umsetzen oder auch anpassen wenn du
einzelne gemüse durch andere austauschen
möchte ist habe ich dir im plan noch mal
erklärt wie das funktioniert alles ganz
einfach ja aber um einen kanal wenn du
es noch nicht gemacht hast trick auch
die glocke dass du informiert wirst wenn
ich neue videos mache und gebt mir einen
daumen nach oben wenn es dir gefallen
hat ich freue mich über eure kommentare
nächste woche sprechen wir über die
fruchtfolge da freue ich mich auch schon
drauf bis dahin schauen